there are a lot of extremists out there
if you turn tune into uh some british
morning show i don't even know the name
of it they're really concerned about
extremist
language here here's the if you hear
your kid
using these kinds of words
you better intervene quickly
they're finding these young boys on on
gaming sites and and um can parents look
out for maybe language that they use
young their young sons might be using
behavior that they might have yes they
can so there are lots of bits of
language that might be red flags
referring to people as normies or as
triggered normies is the word in cells
used for people outside their community
triggered based cucked describing being
red-pilled or pilled which are words
they used to describe being infiltrated
into the ideology and it's worth saying
as well that they see this as a kind of
conduit to other forms of extremism it
isn't completely separate from far white
white nationalists white supremacist
movements they actually really see it as
a slip way so parents might see a
combination of perhaps also racism
creeping in as well the in-cell
community is a very racist community
this is a racist ideology and of course
white supremacist is a deeply
misogynistic ideology
if your son is not a cuck if he does not
want to be a cuck he might be an
extremist white supremacist my my
british accent is getting worse and
worse by the day
as though [ __ ] which is
one of the oldest insults in the world i
mean italians actually have different
symbols they wear it as jewelry the
little horn thing it looks like or the
little the like the rock star symbol
that italians were that's the symbol of
the cornuto of the [ __ ] the cuckold the
idea that your wife is cheating on you
you've got an unfaithful wife this is a
very basic insult there are many of
these others as well but if you use them
some of which are quite dated now
actually your kid is an extremist
no better than a terrorist you've got to
watch out all every all the
conservatives are terrorists
all the leftists wonderful great people
we've got to kick one group out of
society and society's only fit
for the other one
stop
don't go don't leave me i need you i
need you to go to apple podcasts or
spotify or google play or stitcher or
whatever whatever you wherever you get
your podcasts type in the michael
knowles show
click
subscribe
then wait for that to populate in your
feed maybe leave it a five-star review
if you don't mind and leave a comment
right here and say hello to me on
youtube we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you